Село Невір Волинської області.
Тут жодного разу не лунали вибухи чи сирени.
Про війну нагадують хіба протитанкові їжаки при в'їзді.
Живем, поки ми живемо. Ніхто нас не чіпає, і ми нікого не чіпаємо.
Гаруємо, садимо бульбачку, їмо.
Люди страждають, але ми ще нічого не маємо, що війна.
Хто знає, як буде далі. Не знаю.
85-річна пані Оксана чула вибухи востаннє ще за часів Другої світової.
Тємлю, як німці були… Німці тутка були, но ніколи людей не ображали, знаєте?
Щоб комусь шо зробили, чи що.
Ще треба ще одну війну? Ой-ой-ой.
Ще жить і жить. Хай би ті молоденькі жили, а хай би я вмерла.
Що буде далі, у Невірі загадувати не беруться.
Адже звідси до Білорусі - менше трьох кілометрів. Кордон проходить просто за цим лісом.
Про можливий наступ з боку Білорусі місцеві мешканці намагаються не думати.
Село продовжує жити звичним життям: люди пораються на городах, хазяйнують біля хат і запасаються сіном для худоби на зиму.
Фізично війну тут не відчувають, кажуть місцеві, тож і тікати від неї не збираються.
Ми ніколи не втікали. Що буде - те буде! А куди? Далеко втечеш?
Ні, ми не втікали. Мені цікаво жити.
Мені здається, що свого села я ніколи…
Мене діти забирають, але мені здається, що я не пойду.
Мені здається, що Невір - моє серце.
Проте так чи інакше війна торкнулася всіх. Приміром, син пані Ніни зараз воює під Бахмутом.
Він тричі був поранений, але щоразу після лікування повертався на фронт.
Для матері кожен новий день без зв'язку із сином - справжні тортури.
Вони знову не чулися більше тижня.
Живий-живий, виживає. Може, виживає.
Чи мої молитви чує? Чи що? Вже три рази був поранений.
Один у мене син, синочок, і той на війні.
Він з першого дня, він у Полтавській області жив, його з роботи забрали одразу.
Серед жителів Невіру чимало й волонтерів.
Приміром, пан Степан допомагає військовим чим може: коли передасть на фронт мед, а коли - автівку відремонтує.
То машина Збройних сил України.
Хлопці 26 травня виїжджали, обламалась деталь, то я зробив.
Зараз вони на "нулі". Але один поранений лежить у госпіталі в Запоріжжі.
Треба машину відігнати хлопцям-одеситам на "нуль". Вчора зідзвонилися.
По той бік кордону - у Брестській області - у пана Степана близькі родичі.
Утім, після нападу Росії на Україну чоловік їх зрікся.
За Радянського Союзу разом жили, ходили, женились, гуляли, пили, колядували, а тепер - вороги.
У мене рідна сестра, племінник там. Ми не говоримо.
Стала война - все. Вони: "Що ви робите? Амерікоси… Ми ще не воювали з вами".
Все, к чортовой матері їх! Півтора роки спілкування ніякого.
І у Невірі це не рідкість. Чи не кожна тутешня сім'я має родичів по той бік кордону.
Адже після розпаду Радянського Союзу велика кількість мешканців прикордонних сіл
виїхали до Білорусі у пошуках кращого життя.
З нашого села більше живе в Білорусі, ніж тут - у селі в Україні.
Переїхали ще тоді, коли колгоспи розсипались.
Тобто звикли, що дать чоловікові в руки - й він буде працювати.
Та слабо ми там заробляли.
Хто зерно, хто картоплю, а гроші - слабенько заробляли.
Роботи в Невірі немає. До вторгнення РФ селяни виїжджали на заробітки.
А тепер, коли кордони закриті й ретельно охороняються,
неможливо ані виїхати в Європу, ані переправити контрабанду в Білорусь.
Я так само носив і сигарети, і все, що попало, тому що треба було копійку зробити.
Роботи ж немає. Всі так, не один я. От, наприклад, треба зробити.
Зібралися, перевезли там сигарет, ще щось, муку привезли, цукор привезли.
Тому заробляли, щоб жити.
Тобто була тут взагалі контрабанда, тут прикордонна зона.
Тут взагалі контрабанда була в таких масштабах, в будь-яких. І одежа, і телефони.
Все, що йшло в Білорусь, в Росію, все йшло ось сюди. Зараз нема, звісно, зараз війна.
Нині ж пан Степан живе на одну пенсію, а для душі - займається пасікою.
Коли я працював шофером - я не займався, мені не було коли.
А коли пішов на пенсію - відновив батькове ремесло.
У мене пасіка, більш як 20 сімей, вулики, мед роблю.
У мене є онучки дві. І людям даю всім.
Кому треба й кому не треба - все одно всім даю, хто приходить.
За розмовою дізнаємося: саме цього дня подружжя Токарчуків святкує сорок років шлюбу.
Сьогодні у нас рубінове весілля.
Але б хотілося спокою, перемоги, щоб скоріше закінчилася війна.
Щоб хлопці повернулися живими й здоровими. Вдома їх чекають.